so four people on the livestream this is
another internal design review meeting
for the upcoming version of Wolfram
language this particular one is about
interest in new calculus functionality
calculus not being a finished area even
after all these years so looks like we
are primarily dealing with asymptotics
is that right oh we also have the
elementary algebra stuff oh cool okay
fine all right was it gonna be these are
going to be two very different pieces
okay let's talk about asymptotics so can
I run some of this stuff yeah in
external okay should I go to the
documentation page yeah well my
documentation thing is broken here
doesn't open that okay asymptotic
integrate
you
is it I mean
there's no meaning - I mean like
asymptotics soul or something like this
why isn't there a meaning that's some
kind of limit combined with solve or
something is that right or is that hmm
you get what you get is an asymptotic
approximation to the solutions yeah it's
more like series solutions so
asymptotically solve value you can think
very much as you know power series
solutions differential equations so why
isn't this called series integrate
because series some people think that
serious is something like for air series
which are not asymptotic
I understand but this is returning an
integrator is right no it does not
return a series so we want these to be
experimental now because we want to
maintain the option of changing the
output at some future date but so women
so this is the fundamental problems is
the limitations of series you know and
it there might be fundamental problems
we just don't fully understand those
problems yet okay but so let me
understand this so this is the integral
of e to the T times X with T I don't
understand this you integrate from from
0 to 1 but you view acts as a parameter
you want to expand it around 0 do you
read a use case reader use its message
yeah I did okay so it's a star there so
I did
okay so the indefinite integral here so
I should be able to do the indefinite
integral here
yeah
okay so the trivial case is something
like me knew why didn't that work
you need to have you know in the
indefinite case then it steed you know
why didn't that work with just a single
one because there's no X in there
anything no what
well that's a good point but but
realistically what you were asking for
is two very T around some numb you know
okay so it's just a bug that one doesn't
work I think so but okay look it's just
T is that correct sorry if it did work
if one did work it would just give T
something independent of X correct
good Yuki yes but but do you have you
you the XS the one you specified the
expansion point around
now I understand okay so if I compare
that with integrate
okay and then I say series of that x07
give the same and under once at what
circumstances won't it give the same if
there is no series for instance series
can't represent it if the different
asymptotic scale has been chosen okay so
in particular then if what I do here is
I say square root of arc tan
you
you
okay
you
okay I mean I'll even be an integral
that we can do yeah and there are simple
things like X to the X yeah I understand
I don't understand why it's called
asymptotic I mean I'm doing it around
the point zero here
I mean asymptotic is usually you know
and infinity or some such other no
asymptotic at this at any point not at
all
okay why isn't this called integrate
series or series integrate right it's so
what so it's right because we're not
necessarily guaranteeing any sort of
convergence right so Assam right this is
asymptotic like in the in the way that
QD expansions are asymptotic they reach
the minimum point and are useful but
they don't actually converge okay fine
but but but isn't that the case series
also if you do series on something with
an essential singularity for example
okay that's interesting how did series
manage to get a result there because it
doesn't use
[Music]
it doesn't use integrate well it
differentiated the integral rate I see
so it treated that as a formal object
and did this differentiation okay but so
show me an example so if I if I have
something with an essential singularity
for example so for instance let's say I
have you know sign 1 over X or something
let's do something like that ok so now
if I say integrate that thing over T I
presumably get a result okay so now
explain this to me I've grown a series
here maybe this isn't relevant one to do
a series with respect on my goal okay so
what assumptions do I need well it's
sort of interesting because that's
different result no but I've got a log X
term that no I mean this isn't bad I'm
simply trying to understand the
difference between asymptotic integrate
and series of integrate sure maybe this
is an example where there is actually a
difference don't forget that log of X is
zero and with respect to this with
respect to series expansion this is the
log x times X there's no cont is that a
constant of integration there it might
log 1 over T sure isn't a constant of
integration know that that could be a
constant integration but this isn't log
1 over T okay so walk me through again
why is asymptotic integrate not the same
as series of integrate
in the indefinite case the main that
there can be a couple of reasons one is
a constant you know an indefinite
integral is only defined up to a
constant yes okay
that's one potential big deal okay fine
I mean we could have sixteen different
versions of integrate which choose
different make different choices of
constants that's right
we've never been into that particularly
because no matter no it doesn't really
know the other thing that can happen
because of the solution methods it might
pick different base asymptotic scale if
you like to express the solution right
and I think maybe one sort of difference
that's wrote we easy to understand is
that asymptotic and agreat tries to give
you about n terms
whereas series gives you gives you
quote-unquote order and whatever that
means which in some cases is fewer than
n terms and in other cases is more than
n terms and that's in some cases it's
really quite mysterious what its meaning
of n is of order n is
[Music]
so yeah that interpretation of what
order means cannot stay
it just makes it makes sort of sense if
you're in power series it makes perfect
sense okay but the minute you sort of
leave power series it starts to be that
more and more vague and when you get
more complicated scales it gets you know
it's like who knows what it means no
idea what it means even
um and and the thing is that you know
essential singularity basically means
not poll right and and it's not that the
polls and and no singularities aren't
interesting but often the really
interesting case is when you go beyond
that
sorry sorry I spaced out from that could
you go go back and and repeat this so
I'm trying to understand retry on this
on this asymptotic integrate versus and
a great thing versus series will
integrate most of the time they will
give very similar results they should
always be equivalent in some sense okay
if if series can succeed if integrate
can succeed etc etc hmm okay but the the
essential property that asymptotic
integrate guarantees is that you get a
result that is asymptotic at the point
that you specify
and what a series guarantee I don't know
it's not clear what it guarantees seems
hard to guarantee I mean so you're
saying that I mean this whole question
about being asymptotic mm-hmm isn't that
really a nasty complicated question in
the world of essential singularities and
all these kinds of weird things that's
almost the only thing you have that you
can guarantee
it's not super simple but I think that
we will be able to not like undecidable
well I mean it's all of our symbolic
functions our undecidable if you you
know see
recognition is undecidable so all of our
symbolic functions are undecidable
okay let's I'm a little bit confused
here but let's keep going because I
think we're going to this may be a
little bit clearer you know when we talk
about asymptotically greater than hmm
let's let me understand that so I mean
for example Assam so can you give me an
example let's let's take a look here of
asymptotic greater I actually if you
were to pick one of them I would pick
asymptotic less because or if you want
to look at the illustrations asymptotic
less equal
which one did you pick that's a girl
Atlas okay
think so what is what what are these
things being
you
okay X Y goes to infinity great those
are kind of trivial but what where is
some that are non-trivial
whether it did examples are not
developed here yet they are missing a
bunch of examples but I wanted to show
you some applications okay and okay so
if you can slow down because yeah okay
good
so for instance
you can see the basic applications that
there's sort of gonna be intuition
builders a stay often are hmm but then
you can see here this is this a notion
of approximation absolute error small
absolute error means that and the
difference is something that's gonna
have limit zero as X goes to zero okay
and that's saying that it's
asymptotically less strictly less than a
constant yes okay
so you see a few examples there there
not too many but a few but gets you that
concept okay but these are all pretty
trivial examples
yeah that how else can you learn no I
understand but what are the non trivial
examples I mean the ones with like
series expansions I mean with like sums
and so on so you can go down to the
there should be something about
asymptotic both yeah so oh where is that
and somewhere in here like come on if I
go to commoner toric so do I see non
trivial stuff there not yet proximation
yeah okay okay so in this sense what
you're saying is hmm okay so but
asymptotic equal doesn't have the same
order thing that asymptotic integrate
has it's just saying here are two
functions and that's is that the same as
what less doesn't less isn't less wear
Uggs
oh goodness sake not the stupid problem
again I already to fix this it is ver
argh asymptotic orders are undefined
unless you specify at which point and
you Nelson on that right I understand
that point so I'm asking the question
okay yes yes it is okay so this is a
design this is a slightly weird design
change here because the asymptotic glass
is not a mirror of less it's an order
and they're more orders in the world
than less yeah okay but it has this X
goes to infinity it needs to yeah
hmm okay but in what sense assassin
dropp'd asymptotic integrate has an
order in a different sense of order by
the way we've got a bunch of weird
background noise no it has an order in a
asymptotic order what you say is that
whatever you sort of haven't given us an
answer yet
you know the rest you know if you kept
on doing a higher and higher order
actually look at the inside of me saying
it inwards look at the page for
asymptotic integrate that explains what
it is that it guarantees
can you just scroll by it yeah but but
look Roger the thing that I'm concerned
about is asymptotic integrate is a
series like function that specifies an
order of expansion asymptotes what order
means order in the sense of this order
not order in the sense of polynomial
degree
what do you mean by that what I mean is
I think you're confusing some type of
class and that's I'm sorry can't agree
asymptotic integrate guarantee is a
particular number of terms No
it does not
soon to be seven terms here no it does
not
at 7:00 thought that looks like it's
seventh order in axe
like the polynomial pick just can't hold
true to just at the polynomial business
just just know everybody's a Quisling
this case here it's to order 7 in
polynomial orders right I mean if I were
to choose something here where I've got
a very high degree where X here is X to
the 10th right I would see something
fairly trivial what the heck am I saying
about to see here
okay
I'm about to see that because even
though I asked for seventh order and
there just weren't any orders that could
be gotten yeah there we go
right I'm only getting that order
because I don't have
they know all other orders I'm only
searching for up to polynomial order X
to the seventh
I'm making sense
yeah okay so so I don't understand what
does that order actually mean what does
that number actually mean it basically
it go ahead yeah
it's if you read the documentation okay
to see that paragraph says if the exact
result is G yeah and the nautical works
and then we have asymptotic series
hasn't got less
right now if it so happens that
is a sum and also a series hell you know
due to the next paragraph there
see below the illustration okay so now
to start it scales such that this is
true
I see so so your point is there is a
property which is that
I don't understand this that there is
some asymptotic less and greater
property that holds given given this
order here now I'm really confused I'm
sorry
what's why do I have to state so so
these things here are always bullying's
is there ever and I don't know response
from asymptotic glass yeah it can give
conditions on parameters and other
things
okay but it doesn't do that with I
presume if you put an A in front of the
X and the exponential it'll give you a
conditional expression
you
okay it's just
probably the opposite of what it should
do but you mean it should give the true
and a you know less than 1 or between
minus 1 and 1 or whatever it is that it
wants to be
it's certainly false when it is greater
than 1 but right more useful would be if
somebody saying something we can't hear
you
you
okay hi I'm still I'm sorry
so let's do the following can we just
for the sake of the flow of this meeting
can we jump down to what I think are
really straightforward things sure um
and let's come back to this I'm pretty
seriously confused by this and I'm
seriously confused I mean you you you
believe that the term asymptotic is used
in the same way an asymptotic integrate
as it is an asymptotic greater that true
yeah and what you're not doing here is
some kind of thing where it's just kind
of like series is broken so we're going
to rebuild it
or is that I need we need a future
extension of holder as Stamkos um so so
here's the scenario round series we've
been doing some functionality is using
the output of series series can only
work for expressions it can't work for
solvers at this point but we want it to
eventually what do you mean by solvers
you mean implicit yeah things like room
can integrate or or a solve or D souls
or things like that what do you mean it
can't work for those I mean it currently
doesn't and what so if I have an
undervalued solve it seems to me you
know a none evaluated solver and unev a
late to D so van done evaluated
integrate I should be able to do get the
series of that right which we noticed
you could do back up here like right
here it did that
so occasionally it might work
okay okay but it generally doesn't okay
but it but it should it should okay but
here's the problem the output of series
has been serious the serious data
structure is designed to deal with power
series formal Laurent series and formal
puso series but it was hacked really and
really for the univariate case because
and for univariate own right so it needs
to be extended I mean it was high okay
essential singularity type stuff and so
on wasn't it that's right which means
that you can't really you know first of
all it can't represent things so it
represents things weirdly I understand I
agree it's a very old it's a 31 year old
structure yes now I mean we design a new
series we need to know what it needs to
represent I agree okay hence we're
building the solvers that will generate
these series okay so just walk me hoping
that's not clear that the design of
series of auto expanding when things
come up inside it's also not clear that
that's gonna be able to work for
sufficiently general series
well then we need something where it can
I mean just like if you type in you know
- what I'm saying is that we cannot have
a new series right now
no I guess there is nothing so an
outline right you know the analog of
that is you know X plus X simplifies but
some more complicated thing does not so
one would assume the same thing will
happen with series just like here we're
effectively seeing that happening right
we're seeing a fine Laurent series
inside here right but the thing cannot
resolve to a complete series because it
doesn't know how to represent the
essential circularity right correct okay
so then what we want to do I guess so
I get your point and I agree that you
know these okay so the goal then is to
make certain experimental functions
which are the beginnings of a by the way
do we think that in the sort of
development post Hardy fields and all
this kind of thing do we think there is
a well-developed mathematical theory
that would allow us some principle to
represent these series or do we think
that the theory is undeveloped at this
time
it's a little bit of both and we are
proceeding to get to know and develop
that as we speak and this developing des
solvers is part of that but in the
univariate case in particular the
multivariate case needs substantial
attention okay I understand and now
leads pretty far but very power of
question here so when Hardy invented
Hardy fields
he thought he was imitating orders of
infinity in the cantorian sense
I mean he thought he was doing a
transplant number play I believe
I think what turned out to be the case
is the those transfinite numbers have
turned out to not be very useful for for
instance infinitesimals and these hyper
reels
so that's effectively not used there
what what is a hyper-real when you have
when you have infinite decimals or
infinite City manipulable you know I
heard of hyper wheels but how do they
differ so I mean the the cantorian model
was a particular model which included
him infinities and infinitesimals you're
saying there is a different model yes
okay and cantorian did not include
infinitesimals you don't know I
understand he was only doing for
infinity right right but but so my
question to record he did that but you
know in in in later development it
turned out he didn't do what the
infinitesimals it wasn't it was not
sufficient but I mean Cantor's original
goal was some stuff to do with
trigonometric series if I'm not mistaken
I mean he was trying to do something a
bit like what we're trying to do here
um except you know one hundred and
thirty forty years ago I'm right let's
just walk me through though is there a
so is there a systematic way I mean
in it just like there are orders of
infinity and things like that are there
similarly is that kind of the analog
like I think Hardy tried to do with
Hardy fields of these sort of orders of
expansion and so on yeah
yes so if you have so what what's
reasonably well I mean it's we're mixing
many things here so I'm trying to answer
constructively and more you so one thing
that you know and we know is that we
need in order to tackle essential
singularities or otherwise known as not
poles okay we need to have a richer set
of scales to extremis that it yep okay
and some of that is already built and
inside you know Mathematica Wolfram
language meant you know particularly in
the new limit functions make extensive
use of that so do we have a symbolic
representation of those new scales no
and is that I mean is there an ending
just like like when you have an
exponential scale for example is there
some meaningful sense in which there is
a numerical index that might be a trans
finite number but is there some
numerical index for that or is it just
not thought of in that way it's not
thought of in that way because the probe
see it if we if you if you and
predefined
I ask you Stephen if you're gonna use
this function you need to tell me what
scale you're gonna use and then index
internet you know you would have a close
to zero success rate sure using any of
those functions because you will guess
the wrong scale every time you know
except at least you know except in the
simple cases when the power scale and
other things kind of work well I
understand but I mean that's the
question of what does that number mean
which we were discussing earlier what
does the 7 mean does it mean give me
seven nonzero terms does it mean go up
to order X to the seventh or what is it
well I wish I wish it could could be
terms but but the fact is that we can't
always get a series you can always get
the nessam Tariq approximation and often
it is the series in which case it could
be terms and that's a very long else can
it be other than a series just
blob of stuff so for instance yeah so
just to give you an example if you have
a differential een just a linear
differential equation mm-hmm and you
have an an irregular singular point in
that yep
then what you're gonna get is a pre
factor of an exponential you know
typically have a Laurent series inside
of its argument there okay okay that
grows and then you get the regular
multiplied on to a sort of a regular
power series yep
that itself means it's no longer a
serious no I'm in a fixed K yes this may
or may not be useful but a way I think
one way to think about this is right
just as you have multiple scales of
infinities right you have the cardinal
infinities if you have the ordinal
infinities and they may or may not be
comparable sometimes they're comparable
sometimes they're not really comparable
right this is order seven in an
appropriate scale which may be some sort
of log scale exponential scale so there
are you know are just together normal
are always integers we're not going and
you know this is give me order seven in
an appropriate scale I don't understand
if if we have X to the PI what scale
doesn't that give us yet another weird
set of things going on absolutely you
know but but the asymptotic ness and the
number of sort of steps that you go down
death many steps many times it's still
well-defined
okay yeah no I was just saying that you
can go to asymptotic D so value and just
look at regular singular points because
those already exploit you know that's
the next level up in scales that you
know just one step away from Lawrence
okay sorry typing into this this is a
disaster I mean let me not do that
asymptotic diesel value
now go down to scope examples
which one a regular singular points I
guess okay hmm when you get a little you
know they're simple cases first but
let's see you skip gosh by the way
somebody should report this bug see that
see that ghosted in X there that's wrong
Kandra do we have any lock powers here I
want to show things that are not just
rational numbers right there but I think
you might even get richer set of
examples for the wkb method so if you go
down to singular perturbation problems
you need to need some examples here that
have log powers in them they don't I
don't see any log powers we could put in
something so what do you think singular
perturbations right you see the kind of
unsynced over there from the wkb method
yeah so exactly
gosh that X shouldn't be there that
multiplication sign shouldn't be there I
thought we went through this for this
version oh my gosh
sigh um
I read a really good quote which you
will appreciate yeah so asymptotic
analysis is as confusing for the
advanced student as calculus is for the
freshman
lovely okay so now we gonna make it
elementary you know that's our goal is
there any level at which it's not
confusing I mean yeah no no this will be
these asymptotic orders and all of these
things will you know are you sure I mean
sure it's doable are you sure that the
man yes tangle everything now it will
work
it'll be great okay is this a new
powerful calculus that we're introducing
third mode of computing the what was
what were the first two algebra and
calculus symbolic and numeric oh I see
well your claim is that this is
approximate I mean this is like series
tries to be namely approximate symbolic
computation yes exactly
right but the notion of precision is
unbelievably much more complicated in
this case and particularly for the
multivariate stuff I I have powerful
magic with yeah but but but it's magic
that unlike precision which is
parametrized able by a single number for
example hmm this is parametrize well how
do we think about parametrizing this is
it parameterizing using some kind of
collections of functions or what what
what kind of a thing would parameterize
the level of precision this
you know two first order approximation
you can still think of it as a series
and then it means the number of terms by
the way there's this you can have a hope
if I give Absalon of to know why did
that so I see so that then wow this is a
complicated creature you can go up quite
a bit up I could impress three or four
tsa files I'm not sure but yeah so it's
like an exponential of a series okay
with some extra hair here the initial
conditions if you remove the boundary
conditions you see the more the nice
structure if I just have no boundary
conditions at all you should start
seeing the structure actually yes okay
all right fine okay it's basically go
away because the Exponential's of
logarithms which got cancelled out I see
so that could be a log in the okay all
right okay this is still not completely
helping me so I mean what you're saying
is I mean one thing that's kind of
annoying is that in the one case in the
case of asymptotic greater asymptote
less whatever you've got something that
looks like a limit going on you know X
goes to 7 or something I expose to zero
right right in the case of asymptotic
integrate you have something like that
going on well I actually we could
discuss that okay because I think we
should use the arrow notation here too
okay
well yeah I mean particularly if you
don't even know what the orders mean
but right I mean this is so this is if
you're saying asymptotic I mean that
would make a lot more sense
asymptotic integrate asymptotic
integrate of f of X and T you know the X
integration and then T goes to blah blah
blah exactly that's basically what
you're talking about yeah except that
what you want to do in the case of the
boolean x' there's no parameterization
that you can give presumably because
what do you mean by that well I mean you
can't say look it's either greater or it
isn't oh yeah right
so what do you do in the case where it
doesn't know what what happens if I say
as another glass if I if I do a very
trivial thing if I say asymptotic less
you know sine sine X 0
are
mean means do not always less yeah it
means that in the limit you know
if you if you did that besides the
message but if you just change that or
if you right but if you in your zero
example if you change that to like to
plus sine of X you know and it should
give you I mean it goes through the low
Falls it was Chris yeah oh I'm a bit
surprised by that well that's a bug no
because right now it's using a 0:02 plus
sine of X is clearly greater than zero I
was thinking the other order zero zero
sine of X are not comparable to the sine
of X is always crossing zero so what I'm
trying to ask is is it it's always the
case that less or greater is a predicate
that has a definite answer if you know
it like for instance if I ask you know
all the zeros of the zeta function um
you know I can formulate the Riemann
hypothesis this way right and we don't
know the answer to that at this time
so
or am i confused here I mean the Riemann
hypothesis just some version of this is
it not I mean yes it will be unveiled in
some cases that's for sure
right but what you don't get is this
well it's right to a certain order but
not beyond that that's right no just
right I mean and if you just think in
terms of little o F is either little o
of G or it's not yes
okay fair enough so
but what isn't there a generic I mean
forget integrate isn't there just a
generic I mean I'm really confused here
there's a zeroeth case of this which is
essentially asymptotic series in some
sense where you're just taking an
expression and you're asking
just hiked series does yes yes there is
okay but but for right now we have we
have serious for that okay okay but we
don't know what the future extension of
serial I understand but we also have
limit limit
okay so limit attempts to just resolve
what is the limit for example in the
case of sign one over X as X goes to 0
limit is just kind of say I don't know
what the limit is well knowing will tell
you what the limit is it will tell you
that the limit does not exist
yeah okay
this one doesn't exist okay that's
correct
okay but is there or is there not some
approximation to that limit that does
exist yeah well you I mean first of all
when you use limits you can use max
limit that exists
and min limit that exists no but I'm
saying the this this is the no no you're
right Steven yes you you can have you
know you can even try serious try series
on I don't know what it will do but I
think we just tried that it just it just
produces a a um
it just does that yeah right okay but so
one thing one thing and that's that's
really interesting with these
asymptotics if you prescribed a scale
like a power scale and you take a
function like yours here or e to the 1
over X at the origin so in the power
scale that entire series is zero
yes what you're trying to express in a
scale I'm aware right I mean that's like
in further for the particle physicists
on this call right that's the that's you
know the whole business about instantons
and non perturbative solution and
physicists usually call these scales
gauges you know among other things
really yeah okay that was vile called at
that back oh maybe it was vile okay not
in a modern world the gauge is something
is something a completely different
direction okay but anyway they go ahead
go ahead the picture right yes the e to
the 1 over X thing is zero in a standard
expansion yeah
but that doesn't mean we can't express
it using asymptotic so just you'd need
to use a different scale where it starts
to register yep but okay but but so then
so what you're saying is you have a
limit but then the kind of the wiggling
is around that limit there's some
expansion of stuff around that limit
that can be represented as a series with
respect to some scale that's right okay
but but so and they really show up
because they need it for instance to
express the solutions of differential
equations and integrals in and etc no I
understand that but so the trade-off
here the thing that's rather bizarre is
this asymptotic less being so asymptotic
less is limit like an asymptotic
integrate is series like that's right
because she got one of them is going to
give a predicate is a predicate with a
boolean answer and the other one is
giving some expression as the answer is
that the idea yeah
this allows you to sort of you know and
you often use this to these asymptotic
relations are used to express a number
of things and we've just made them
computable yeah and I understand what's
the difference in asymptotic equal and
asymptotic equivalent equal is when it's
both Big O and big Omega otherwise known
as big theta ok so what's an example
something which is asymptotically equal
asymptotically equivalent but as a
radical equivalent is stronger than
asymptotically equal is that right
that's right
right I mean X and 2x are asymptotically
equivalent but they're not that's
emphatically equal no but you gotta
weigh around what all the way around
their asymptotic to equal yes big noggin
I thought yes I said that backwards but
that is what I meant yeah okay okay
interesting
all right let's keep going let's we're
gonna loop back to this asymptotic stuff
because it's it's difficult
okay so improved solvers what is it
sorry about that I meant to get that
more clean so there's been numerous
improvements to you know this this limit
functions it's it's
okay this is something we should look at
does it change the design no just more
stuff I need more stuff new examples but
that's about it alright so let's look at
our algebra Adam you are very hard to
hear things that because I'm doing - we
can do now but there is no design okay
all right let's take a look at these
elementary algebra things for a minute
which we looked at I mean these we
looked at these a couple of years ago
didn't we I mean this is I don't know I
haven't been involved in the death yeah
who's reviewed this design well I did
and and I thought Roger had reviewed you
know I've done that too - all right
right and there's so subtract sites and
this is divide sites have a 1 argument
form so right so if you subtract sites a
minus B equals 0 or something right okay
have you tried really using these for
something that is in in for example if
you want to give a derivation has chip
first looked at these I don't know if
chip has looked at these I mean the one
thing I have in the documentation
probably under applications sort of a
derivation of completing the square
yeah you'll just open open open open the
subgroup open the subgroup of
applications it's just about right yeah
and you'll see that you know I need to
like I think somewhere I need to you
know I needed that extra expand at the
end in order to make it right so you see
on the second line after I multiply it
doesn't sort of multiply out the sides I
needed that extra expand wouldn't that
be a good thing to have by default
um okay so there's a little quadratic
formed thing and
Wow what is this assumptions right
you're multiplying both sides of the
equations by E by by a you know pure
factor so we need a to be not zero
otherwise we'd get a conditional
expression oh gosh
and that actually might that might
actually be sort of worth reviewing or
would we get I think we'd get a piece
ways expression oh well well right there
I mean since this is intended to be for
sort of the Elementary I why do we get
this because if a is zero then you've
multiplied both sides of an equation by
zero and that's not defined I mean why
didn't they expand borrow its way into
that conditional expression but
piecewise expression that's a question
for Adam it seems like it should
Roger do you have any comments on that
Pete just which one should expand burrow
its way into piecewise expressions we
have to compare carefully look at that
because that can tip over the whole
system right then I guess the question
is does it burrow just into the you know
equations are also the conditions if you
have piecewise insight inside the larger
expression should go inside the
piecewise that's x max or okay but if I
might say so this marked by sides is not
is in the category of not terribly
useful I mean this is you know we were
trying to provide a function that will
make it easier for people who doing
fairly elementary things by the time
it's zooming off into the piecewise
world I you know it's definitely not in
the easier category well it's it's also
tells you if you want to multiply it by
something you should you should make
make sure it's not equal zero so that's
this is the kind of thing that students
are taught that you know they shouldn't
just blindly multiply by something there
are conditions for that yes yeah if you
look at the multiply sides page they're
they're sort of different settings for
generate conditions
[Music]
Devendra and I felt that piecewise was
less scary than conditional expression
so we so we decided so the default value
is all which is return all possible
answers using piecewise so like for
example if you divide an inequality by a
right you'll have two different answers
one where it's you know where it's
reversed and one where it's not reversed
so I guess my question would be um what
um you know for the
because student at some level generate
conditions are automatic which I would
assume here if I were to do this would
say if I did that and then I said
generate conditions what an earth is
that generate conditions is oh great
that's by the way something to note that
that's autocomplete thing is going to
need to change for this function right
now that point sorry did you understand
that point about the yes okay yes now
what now copy that input and changed
that quadratic to you know be less than
see this here yep as opposed with the
default value and now try that again
without the setting generate conditions
okay so in that sense it's giving you
certainly four inequalities I think
that's sort of a better and and less
scary looking answer yeah it's not
helped by the fact that conditional
expression doesn't format in a nice way
but okay so gosh okay well let me just
tell you I understand gosh there I was
thinking these functions were just
completely trivial structural functions
but they're not so what are the other
gotchas in these functions so I mean
apply sides is both simpler and a bit of
a gotcha right in that it just blindly
applies to function structurally and
doesn't think at all about the
mathematical correctness thereof so it's
just like a map on to the two sides
right
okay it understands things like
equations and inequalities and piecewise
things and whatnot so my question you
were gonna show me how you do the
derivation of completing the square okay
so yeah so go back to multiply sides yep
and under applications so you you may
need to open it up then okay here let me
copy it well yeah in fact I think you
copied it out already and well I copied
it from a different function I felt okay
well you probably did but it's probably
pretty similar okay but at this point
you could get completely the wrong
answer right in fact you are in effect
getting you know that could do just
completely it's something completely
bonkers although you have an equal sign
so it's fine right if two things are
equal to each other they're their
principal square roots are equal to each
other yes but not the square root to
find more broadly and not necessarily
principal square root right yes I mean
so so you'll write so I only derive sort
of the plus the plus guy and there's
also right so where
what are we doing here so we're mmm hi I
guess my question is if you
to represent so we were just talking
earlier today about find equational
proof okay okay and it has these proof
objects that have generate so a
verification function or proof function
we're calling it
and the proof function has the property
that when you in the case of those
proofs you just apply it to nothing it
will go and verify the results so my
question would be what is the analogous
thing that you can do here is there's
some function that you could imagine
generating in some mathematical setting
which is just an apply sides of a
multiplied sides with this or that or
the other I mean in other words these
functions are guaranteeing that they
maintain the correctness of predicates
is that true except I sighs if you want
to prove something that you can't use a
fly sighs right but for other proofs
what you would do is a proof an
algebraic proof would consist of and how
far can you get an algebraic proofs by
just having nested apply sides multiply
sides blah blah blah I don't think I
don't think you can get there without
using things like factor and cancel okay
which are meaning preserving functions I
mean they're right okay but but so then
what I'm asking is what does a proof
look like like the show steps proofs of
off now for something like this what is
a show steps proof look like as a
sequence of apply sides of a you know
multiply sides add sides etc do we know
I'm just trying to get a feeling for
what we could use these functions for
all it is a proof for composition of
these things yes I I believe so as long
as we're long as we're to you know the
four basic operations plus you know
factor expand and cancel then then yes
right the moment you have to take square
roots you're in trouble
sure but so for four straight polynomial
algebra you're saying
these should be enough
but but then what I'm trying to
understand is what will be an example of
something we're in principle we could
say just like we have find equational
proof we could say find algebraic proof
or something and it would basically
become some sequence of these kinds of
operations what would be an example of a
thing you're proving that way that would
be find the polynomial ring proof right
we're in the ring of polynomials because
well what's the thing what's an example
something you could prove yes some
linear equation so I'm actually prove
that x equals 3 given the system of
linear equations right and I think I
have an example of that somewhere maybe
that's under scope rather in terms of
logical operators does that mean that
what that would look like is what you're
proving is blah-blah-blah set of
equations implies x equals 3 is that
right or is that what would be the
actual representation of the thing
you're proving yes a bunch of equations
inequalities it implies something
implies as in our boolean operator
implies yes
huh ok ok so if we yeah I think here let
me find the examples I can tell you
where to look but so maybe
have dissenter properties and relations
of what right so of multiply sides yeah
so like the second and third properties
and relations right so I have an
equation x over three equals five and I
can transform that to x equals fifteen
okay right and but can you you're using
reduce here and using solve oh I see how
it just showed that they give the same
result yeah right right right right
right okay right so basically you can
combine enough multiply sides and divide
sides and add sides to give you reduce
like simplifications assuming you know
you can get there with only those
operation okay is it going to untangle
conditional expressions and piecewise
things correctly
yes I mean it knows how to handle
conditional expressions okay so in other
words when it blows up as a bunch of
conditionals and then in the end every
path leads to the same result that's
going to work is that true
this is true okay that's cool
okay so the the statement given a
certain setting for generate conditions
and for assumptions we should be able to
make the statement you'll never get the
wrong answer
just randomly using apply you know add
sides multiply sides etc is that a true
statement
yes we generate condition goes to true
which which you guys are planning to be
the default condition goes to peace
which is also giving do I think we ended
up calling that all generate conditions
was wrong okay fine so then then the
statement is you'll never get the wrong
answer just using these functions
correct that's cool that's very nice
what's the range of you're saying over
there over polynomials you will never
get the wrong answer but I mean it's not
particularly useful doing this if you
have square roots and things running
around separate statement that's correct
so for that you have to use apply sides
which might give you the wrong answer if
you do the wrong thing all right you're
a square and apply sides you might end
up with something where you know you've
just proved 1 is equal to minus 1 sure I
mean you'd probably end up using a power
expand in order to do that like I do
here yeah so I'm sort of sneaking over
the fact that I know that you can define
square root in such a way that that
power expand is always valid if you
interpret it correctly this will already
fail right because this is oh no I'm
totally confused isn't minus x equals x
doesn't that eval you know it doesn't
devalue it ok so I just proved so there
I mean that's a great example which you
could give in the documentation if you
don't have it already
of apply sides giving the wrong
there is an instance where it's correct
I mean it's not done I mean it's not
actually right it's not wrong it's just
not equivalent to where you started out
well wrong algebraic clay except for X
equals zero
no it's not it's not wrong I mean if
minus X is equal to X then x squared is
minus x squared is equal to X square
enough yeah okay okay I understand I
understand I understand because this
expression you're saying this is you
know for these other ones like multiply
sides and so on the actual expression is
supposed to be equivalent right so it's
a little bit confusing that apply sides
has a name that sounds like multiply
sides but it has the property that it
isn't equivalent right yuck Oh yuck does
that bother you enough that we should
think that think about that some more I
I'm a bit conflicted I think I mean I
documented this as as a possible issue
[Music]
okay but so okay so the typical you know
random person doing algebra actually I'm
curious and a typical derivation that's
done in sort of enth grade algebra or
whatever you know how I guess the number
of nested divide sides multiplied sides
etc will be on the order of I don't know
a few five to ten or something perhaps
is that right I mean that's the kind of
length of our show steps derivations I
think right how about feeling for that I
mean III I would say it's probably
closer to 5 10 to 10 yes okay so by the
way is there a I see and typically
there's a graph of what gets applied to
what so in other words you have an
expression it has something done to it
that's like a node in a graph then you
might have two expressions and then you
do an a multiply I mean sometimes you're
okay question is there a okay so
some of these like add sides there has
there is not a one argument form right
the only one argument form that would
make any sense that right that's right
side go ahead so so divide sites and
subtract sites have the one art form
multiply sides and add sides do not
because I'm not sure what that would do
or be interesting for explain to me in
terms of the you know ring theory or
whatever why that why that's different
in other words go ahead because they're
because it's natural to want well I
guess in terms of ring theory there
isn't that big of a difference but right
it's natural to want
[Music]
- you know get the the unit of your of
the group operation right so four
subtract sides it produces a zero and
four divide sides it produces a one
right so both you're taking one side and
you're applying the named operation to
it to both sides right so you're
subtracting one of the sides from both
sides to get a zero on one side so it
would be a little weird if add sides had
a one argument form because then you're
going to be adding the negation of one
side to both sides and that just seems
weird to me
adding the negation of one side to both
sides in an attempt to get a zero right
I mean because well I mean I'm not sure
what else the one art form would well I
mean I could imagine some bizarre
curried form for one argh
I'm somewhat just thinking about what
does it look like when you have one of
these derivations that is essentially a
functional composition of operations
because it's kind of cool if what it
looks like is you know if the actual
derivation is something that basically
says um with some appropriate you know
multiply sides
um
I'm getting the right composition
operator you know add sides of five
compose with
divide sides
you
since then I got the right of
composition operator they think so um
and that that when applied to you know
that that becomes a derivation basically
[Music]
that's an argument for having you know a
curried form there I suppose right but
then I think you would want
I think it would be weird if ad sides
and multiplied sites had curried forms
but the white sides and subtract sides
do not well right now it's weird that
ads multiply and divide I'm sorry divide
and subtract have one argument forms and
add and multiply do not have one
argument forms I don't think it's that
weird I think it's I mean just like we
have subtract and - which are you know
one organ - argh - signs and but we
don't have you know unary plus and
binary plus yeah Roger have an opinion
about this well I think you're using the
current form in a different sense what
you want to have the one argument thing
to be the thing that you multiply by or
add that case in that carrot form yes
which is kind of crazy which is a
different from what but it has been no I
know it's ice thing is to take the
equation and try and just operate on
that equation now if the thing that's in
there so what does it do if the thing
that's inside it isn't an equation well
that depends on what it is okay so if
it's add sides X comma 6
okay fine by the way it does all the
right things with inequalities right
right this I think this is rather nice I
mean I think this notion of a of a thing
like this that always guarantees to give
the right answer is really pretty
interesting right I mean yes I suppose I
mean help me generalize what what are
some other examples that we could
imagine of operations like these are
guaranteed to get the right answer
operations on expressions or rather
operations on equations between
expressions I mean in principle yeah I
don't know I mean you know applying
monotonic functions to certain things
will guarantee to get the right answer
that's kind of a more obscure case um
well monitor
can order preserving so it's even more
restricted applying function function to
an equation always gives the right well
search an equation but not an inequality
it becomes difficult ok but in the in
the in a sort of symbolic world where
we've got yeah I mean okay in the in the
case of arbitrary axiomatic proofs the
our log of this it's probably something
where you know if if you're yeah I mean
all these axiom all these applications
of axioms are more guaranteed to give
you know if you have a an axiom that
says a equals B and you effectively
apply a to something and B to something
then you will get me most of the case
like including the technology you use
for that find proof equational proof yep
that uses a an enlargement and
rearrangement of the equations that you
study now so Grabner basis is it's very
you know it's the same principle you can
say that that's it gets you that
grosvenor basis is the the resulting
equations that you need to be able to do
reductions and have nothing go wrong to
sure I'm saying that it's like a canoe
and its completion yeah it's a canoe
spandex completion and how does that
relate to what we're talking about here
I mean in other words is there is there
a a more complicated example of this you
know add sides multiply sides that is
essentially the grosvenor basis thing
I mean there are similar things
developed for groups they're similar
things for you know in commutative
algebra it's like the Grabner basis the
similar things but they usually don't
terminate except in some cases for non
commutative algebra and so on right
but those are operations in what sense
ok so so here's a question so if you
wanted to derive for a given for a given
relation you want to derive that
sequence the the functional you know the
functional composition sequence that
leads you from one thing to another what
is the is there a method that is I mean
that would be like you know solving I
don't know some word problem for a group
where you say do this this this or it's
like doing what about theorem proving it
says do you know go from here to here to
here I'm asking in the world of things
like grosvenor bases and in the world of
sort of algebraic computation is there
some well-defined you know existing
operation that basically gives you that
composition of equation transformation
functions yeah I mean Lu decomposition
row reduction Grodner bases they're all
instances of this reduces clearly
basically doing this only two rows
instead of equation rows in the matrix
instead of equations
yeah the composition is the same thing
okay but that's fine but how do we
represent those results you get the end
result row reduce gives you the end
result of it does the transformations
but doesn't show the transformations
okay so were we to want to show the
transformations what would they look
like they would be subtracting a
multiple of one because these these
represent basically linear equations so
you multiply one equation by some
constant you subtract two of them and so
on right so what that is it would be a
subtractive
it will be a subtract side notice that
what we're doing in this case it will be
a subtract sides of a mult
apply sides well actually it's not mouth
by sides it's one equation is it what is
it yeah you can see the mess equations
equal to zero or right so here's
everything right so it will be a
combination of subtract sides and
multiply sides things that in this
particular case happens to be applied to
the matrix representation of the way of
the simultaneous equation then I can
even give you an exact estimate how many
of these just that's the complexity of
row reduction or composition you know I
know that they go like n cubed or
somesuch
of such operations yeah that's
interesting right so in general to solve
an N by n system of simultaneous
equations you're saying that three
general equations like even polynomial
equations that they'll be doubly
exponential in the number of variables I
mean there will be many of them no I
guess that's why I guess that's why kids
end up spending effort doing algebra
because that these things have high
complexity right but really humans still
do that stuff I mean sometimes they're
shortcuts and sometimes you lucky is
sometimes someone adapted a problem so
it's short right but I'm trying to
understand in terms of our add sides
multiply sides and so on what would be
the analogous thing if we were just
operating not on the equations but on
the coefficient list effectively right
because that's what this is that that's
if I'm not mistaken I mean if I have a
set of equations I can how do I go from
the equations to so that's usually
called a vector space right you can
multiply a vector by a constant subtract
vectors and add vectors right so right
when you have a square matrix right so
then that really means M the matrix M
dotted with a pair of variables XY
equals you know 0 0 so it's equations
right so in this sense I mean I guess
you could write so basically multiplies
right so you'd have the first equation
multiply it by whatever you know
I guess one third and then add it to you
know on the itself for another row right
which may be kind of you know trivial in
the square case because the right-hand
sides of the equations are all zero okay
I guess the question that I'm trying to
ask is we've got these multiplied sides
things that operate on explicit
equations represented symbolically
mm-hmm my question is just for the sake
of understanding how these things all
fit together were we to take those
equations and represent them if they're
linear equations just by matrices right
what would be are their functions that
we can imagine that at the analog of
multiply sides that are pipe what does
multiply sides do when it's given a list
nothing they think because it ended for
the elementary case I think it does
nothing is it listable
no I don't think so
actually it is okay which is reasonable
okay but the disembodied equations which
are only equations we can't represent
right so so right well also the point is
right if you're going to do this for a
matrix say then you need to be able to
address individual rows or columns but I
mean you typically often if you teach
people to do that you can't you can sort
of do take things apart and do on
individual equations otherwise you use
dot products and and plus yeah right by
the way someone on our live stream has
asked they want to know given all the
stuff we're doing here what about
symbolic linear algebra working with
vectors and matrices as a whole
it's coming not know I know it's a it's
a chestnut that has been roasting for a
long time well there's more coming so
yeah right
they um but yes we're aware of that it's
an important it's an important thing to
to address and right have some pretty
cool things coming there eventually okay
but let's just okay reviewing multiply
sides and all these things um
I think you've convinced me that your
your generate conditions approach is
correct and actually rather cool even if
there's a certain amount of explanation
that's gonna have to be given to people
about these weird piecewise expressions
that are coming out a question of how
much Auto simplification should be done
is not clear to me and personally I
think given that these are aimed at
fairly elementary things that we should
try to auto simplify when we can would
you like to comment on that and we can
always give an option for a
post-processing option to determine
whether we actually do that but go ahead
what we're going to say just just simply
fun I think so right so what I
personally would want is something that
and maybe this just has to do with the
particular examples I've done but you
know I want something which actually you
know does the multiplication through so
it's sort of like expand but go in and
expand everything it just expands the
new thing yeah well you say multiply
sides you actually want the
multiplication to be you don't just want
it to wrapper them up multiplicand
around the whole thing great so if that
seems reasonable is there a way we have
to do that I mean that's a that's um
right so if you look at the one two
three
the third scope example and what to
multiply sides they're multiplied sides
yes
so that's a case where I would have
wanted to see 7 b + 7 M X rather than I
agree now I think now you can do that
with expand but if you've already
factored one side you know you don't
want to completely expand it how do we
do this isn't there some kind of from do
you want to expand it so if it was a
Mandir there was a plus plus ZX you
would expand it completely what are you
saying here a plus B X here so do you
want happened expanded
no I think what this did is fairly
reasonable then yeah I what I personally
would not object to that being expanded
but yeah I guess it but if it's a sort
of yeah I guess you just say how do you
decide if it's it's a simple thing but
okay so my only real objection then is
that expand doesn't go inside this
piecewise that I think is crazy I think
we just so the issue is this is so if
there's if not the whole thing is
piecewise but it's piecewise inside an
expression should still go inside or not
you mean they expand the actual expense
to go inside something boy what does
expand do if I say F of you know X plus
1 squared or something nothing they
expand that I think it'll do nothing
right yeah okay so Mike statement would
be if the piecewise is I mean there's a
certain certain set of structures if
it's it look if it's inside does expand
all go inside of piecewise everything
yeah so right so if you changed to spend
all of percent 34 no these about okay
but I think okay so the question is is
piecewise and algebraic like operation
but give me what what is a case where
expand all has different behavior from
expand well I I guess the person okay so
this this thing here expand all would go
inside what what do we imagine its
expand all is a very very very old
function what was it
for
I think it's you know for cases where
you have like a trigonometric functions
and things like that
yeah its square roots right
okay fair enough boy it doesn't go
inside held arguments and the arguments
of piecewise are are technically held so
this way it doesn't happen soon right by
the way what does multiply sides doing
with with logical combinations of
equations it should do thing but it
should do the right thing it should it
should go and apply to all of them so if
I say multiply sides of x equals 5 and y
equals 2 multiply sides by 5 that surely
should work along boolean function with
arguments being equations inequalities I
think so why wouldn't it and other non
trivial things that happen there well I
mean for one thing your well I guess you
don't have a cracked site so the
combining the conditions on this
operation being correct for all the
equations inequalities may be
complicated well that's good then we're
adding value I mean what should that do
that should probably subtract sides from
each part of that boolean expression
okay but consider you know consider
divide sides of a equals B okay okay and
now suppose we had you know divide sides
of a equals B and something else what is
even going on here I don't understand
okay okay so wait a minute if I see so
the first case there this is really a
somewhat incomprehensible display of
piecewise why you better because true is
the default case and it's like what a
weird thing I mean so the first the fact
that we format okay question if we
weren't trying to be faithful to the
internal representation of piecewise how
would we format a default
like this I mean the own we might say
otherwise in fact it might even do that
in traditional form or maybe that's an
alpha thing oh yeah I remember we did do
that an alpha because this was really
incomprehensible right what happens if
we do that we say solve that it's a
profoundly useless result okay well I
mean it's useful as far as whatever um
okay so that's another thing we probably
should look at it's at least changing
that traditional form okay Ted that
should be pretty easy - whatever it does
an alpha which I think we thought about
quite carefully okay but in a case so
the boolean case so if the right hand
side this is not an equation and if you
have combinations in holding left hand
side in the right hand side I have no
idea what to put this I'm sure I've had
some this originally started out as a LD
and then it came to me and do you have
any idea where we stored it here it's
turn now I don't know is there an ILD
folder and there it might be though that
is the ILD folder okay then maybe I
think maybe under variables I feel like
it was like no that that can't be right
I do not lose my for that oh well okay
I'll store it under algebra calculus one
hopefully we'll move it later
okay all right so oh gosh we're we're
overtime horribly here um I can't
believe that these functions which I
thought was so simple actually quite
non-trivial right I'm still not sold on
the handling bullion conditions because
right then you're going to get bully ins
of piecewise expressions and so what I
mean what else would you get there so in
other words somebody comes in okay so
here's a question
I see the piecewise expression
is a bully enough no it isn't it's it's
a it's a piecewise of equations right so
yeah that that piecewise is boolean
valued right see I'm saying the values
kick em can be boolean value and also
the piecewise itself is a bunch of
implications isn't it yes or yes
okay but
what's the combination when we put in a
okay we put in a boolean expert my
question is as somebody tries to
generate a derivation do they end up
with a situation in which they have a
boolean bait
they clearly end up with piece rises as
part of their derivation do they end up
with boolean z' as part of that
derivation for any reason des that thing
Stephen if you take that their value
there but where your mouse was yep the
boolean piecewise if you do Adam how do
we get that to a boolean fully expand
which is right now okay reduce to a
single boolean Stephen but they kind of
you can see it like that can be
expressed as a boolean formula that says
basically Z greater than zero and Y Z
greater than that thing you have to have
the negation of your condition yep
just less than or equal to zero like
it's like constructing a CNF DNF type
thing kind of but it bit because normal
boolean care and normal piecewise cares
about orders you have to include the
negation of the previous clauses for
conditions yes okay fair enough okay so
what's your point so your point is that
that I mean in principle it is a boolean
you know in this case right so okay so
then being up so just to understand
there is a correct mathematical answer
to multiply sides with a boolean first
argument true or not true yes it's not
an equation no I don't know that it's
that I mean I suppose it's I guess it
would not be wrong to apply it to each
individual thing in the inequality but
it's not obviously useful or interesting
okay but it is used for interesting if
as an intermediate stage you get out
those boolean expressions just like you
might get out a list and you want to not
have to map and to the you know in
inside that thing but but let me make it
more difficult okay let's just say just
for the sake of argument that we have
something like you know X plus y equals
equals 9 or X minus y is less than 5
okay is there anything sensible we can
do with that I mean you're branching
what's that when structures come out of
it well okay so what we want to be the
case is these are meaning preserving
things so right now there is no other
means to divide both sides by
a boolean valued thing what IIIi don't
know what it means to divide by X plus y
equals 9 or X minus y less than 5 well
what it means is I think there's a just
you know you distribute over the or
somehow that is if you say you've got a
single thing and you're dividing it by
blah or blah does that not mean that you
have thing divided by first blah or
thing divided by second blah okay what
does it mean that the thing is meaning
meaning preserving that is it better be
the case that if the equations were true
yes that the equation that the that if
you that if what it means is that if you
reduce the first thing the input
equation or you know the input first
argument by the output you know if you
reduce first argument is equivalent to
output you get true it's true and then
the output is true so there is an
implication going one way and in the
easier cases where we don't have the
boolean combinations it's also clear to
you what we should do how we should
derive things from from the input I mean
we can derive true from everything so so
there is always some results that will
preserve the implication but what's the
meaningful results for this that to me
all right so look okay let's not solve
this here you know clearly what we put
into 11.3 will be somewhat incomplete
but let's continue to think I don't
think the design is going to change okay
you agree I mean but we should think
through what are all the cases we can
deal with I agree that there should be
no Auto expansion inside these things
but expand should do the right thing
itself I think in terms of
the pure matrix case that is you know
the the how do we see the steps in a row
reduce I think this isn't you know you
know you can obviously
right I mean that the derivation of
steps is a different matter that's more
like a proof thing and it's an
interesting exercise for somebody to to
figure that out it's a good I will add
it to my list of student projects um
um I think it's an interesting um
interesting thing for somebody to do but
I don't think I don't think we need to
but you're telling me that in the world
of like Grodner basis stuff and so on
that there isn't a pre-existing kind of
I mean it is it is an algorithm not some
piece of like Thoreau reduction
algorithm what is the row reduction
algorithm anyway and it's Gaussian
elimination of some kind yes it is
exactly Gaussian elimination but it's
Gaussian elimination something for which
there is a deterministic algorithm or is
it something yes yes there are many
variants of it but yes it's
deterministic but what I mean by that is
you know when you do it by hand you're
kind of looking around for how can I add
these two pieces so that will get I'll
get a simple answer and so but that's
because you want a shortcut it you know
I say yeah I mean you basically the
algorithm is you you you know you make
the first one you know one then you go
to the second one you make it zero one
and then you start canceling others
right well one one and then you can't
make all the subsequent entries in the
first column zero and then you go to the
second and so on and so forth and you
rearrange things if it's missing zeroes
or whatnot okay so question for these so
we haven't done knitting for these
things by the way and also as a question
of are we gonna make believe these
experimental or are they going to be non
experimental these functions
I think it's sort of up to you I don't
think they have to I mean you know if
you feel like allowing the relation rel
to be and in the qua you know a compass
a a boolean combination of relations is
if you feel that's really different then
I don't that different
no I think that extension right so then
that's the next thing you know that's an
extension we may not have in two days
but right and it's an easily audible
extension yes
okay let us make them real do you really
want to say add X there isn't that a bit
confusing just in terms of documentation
as opposed to what well I don't know
it's expert for example I guess I just
thought X was simpler for the intended
audience but if you think what I'm
worried about is X is itself a variable
did I see
[Music]
changing that X to X / okay can you do
that then okay
the okay hold on where's the other one
we've got one more of these guys apply
sides multiply sides divide sides sides
what's that subtract
okay is there a guide page there isn't a
guide page for these guys as them no I
and I don't think I put them on any yet
okay so that is do you have back
pointers to these guys from other stuff
like reduced and solve and so on
I don't think I've done that but it's
easy enough to do
fair enough um we might want to do one
lost one quick look at thee we always do
knitting posties review Stephens thought
it there's nothing mind fine fine
surprise okay alright last moments here
going back to the much more complicated
story okay I thought this was going to
be like super easy
I mean you will be comfortable with it
soon enough which thing the asymptotics
would be I thought that would be
somewhat easy
I thought these ad sides and so on will
be like totally trivial 2-minute things
I see yeah well that's the thing of
keeping track of conditions is not no I
know it's not easy okay so just on the
asymptotics business so the main design
thing that I'm a little bit confused by
is why do we have asymptotic integrated
asymptotic decel value and not
asymptotic every other function that
we're dealing with we will we plan three
more then I have another question like
you know with series we don't have to
have series integrate and so on right
now because integrate applied to a
series does the right thing that's right
so my question is in this situation is
there an analogous kind of you know I'm
an approximate expression rapper that we
could use that's what I want to figure
out I want to release them
experimentally now fine and then we want
to figure out whether we need to report
on their different levels of reporting
one can imagine depending on follow on
use cases of the error term yeah and and
and Steven I guess one one reason we
don't want that function right now is
that in order to make it work right so
if you're thinking of some sort of
asymptotic expand with the first
argument being ste saw value or
integrate or whatever you have we would
need that would function would have to
be hold first yeah yeah yeah right and
we don't want that but an alternative
thing to do would be to say to wrap the
equation in some kind of asymptotic
equation thing and say this whole
equation is supposed to be true I don't
know we could wrap a variable in that
thing something like that I'm not sure I
mean what we're asking for is not X of T
we're asking for the asymptotic X of T
in some sense right there a variety of
other places we could put it
what concerns me is we don't really want
to have you know 50 functions that all
have the asymptotic word in them no the
operation is really different right so I
think that right we don't want
asymptotic Laplace transform is
asymptotic inverse Laplace transform but
still we want asymptotic methods so I
think that we will figure out a wrapper
that we can use for that fine fine all
right okay so and you were raising this
question about I mean I'm still a little
bit confused about the difference
between the boolean switch return true
or false and these other things which
return expressions and the fact that the
specification I guess I mean okay so
let's talk about that precision I mean
in the case of numerical precision it's
a little bit weird because we we will
give a definite answer for a boolean
yeah what do we do what Sweden Utley
tries were definitely both yeah I
understand but what do we do um what do
we do in this case if we say n of
one-third comma 10 greater than n of 1
third comma 20
stand out so there are error bounds for
both of those things
right up to the precision of the lower
one they're equal to each other so one
is not one of them lives inside in this
particular case they it lives inside but
could it not live in a in an overlapping
but this joint or a region
I mean clearly if I say interval one to
greater than interval 0 1
so greater than equal to
what is that doing what is that doing oh
it's okay I mean they only all that than
one point one is greater than is greater
than or equal to a ring them every other
number in the second one
oh I see what is in this case it can't
decide that right
but isn't that similar to the asymptotic
les business
am I being confused here if we had some
serious that would carry the precision
like what they are what their honor
approximation is then it could factor
into the asymptotic lesson we don't have
it yet it's mine but could asymptotic
les ever be confused in the same way
that les is greater or whatever is
confused with intervals I mean we can
compute I can confuse pretty much any
function no I understand it but it but
generically this is a case where the
asymptotic thing is representing a
function right asymptotic les is about
functions yes wiggle around all over the
place that's right right
and in particular it's about the
absolute values of those functions yes
okay but so my question is are there
cases like the case of this interval
here where the answer to asymptotic les
is it's not well-defined
only if we have the imprecise function
so it's if we have approached asymptotic
approximations to functions rather than
the functions if there are East
functions to know so like with the graph
of the two functions
you know intersects each other
repeatedly what is it greater than was
it not greater than it's not greater
than greater is only if it's not so what
about it greater than equal it's lightly
different so with numbers it's greater
greater equal is the same either greater
or equal in case of function whether
it's not necessarily married or it may
be greater equal and the negation of
greater is is not less equal increase of
functions that can cause us trouble I
mean in other words if we I see so what
you're saying is there is no way I mean
that's actually an argument against the
thing I was saying of having an
asymptotic wrapper around an expression
because then the whole every aspect of
our inequality handling will no longer
work for these asymptotic things am i
making sense what if the things that are
inside the greater less and so on aren't
ordered numbers but are instead these
functions so I mean I think one thing
you need to keep in mind about
asymptotic quarters is that they are
partial orders so for example if you do
add some particle s of sine of X cosine
of X as X goes to infinity
that'll give false but also it's
negation of asymptotic greater equal to
understand this so as I'm talking about
sine X cos x X goes to infinity
it's going to give false right and it's
also the case this asymptotic greater
equal of that is also false I see yes
that's obvious
hi okay I get it right right right right
Rotom it's like we can think of this in
terms of yeah okay we have many more of
these partial orders coming for other
domains give me one example just vote or
ordered vague we need ordered vector
spaces for optimization so and in the
case of ordered vector spaces that can
all be defined by what's a convex cone
and yeah I was seeing some of those
things about cones I it's an awfully
technical meaning of cone isn't it no
well we'll come back to that this is for
today right it's like a whole story
there
it'll be very clean nice okay all right
well listen so what's our conclusion
here here's our conclusion that we just
put these in experimental II I guess so
I think we should it's pretty cool
Steven you know I agree it's cool you
missing an echo sound ague on Monsieur
although it doesn't exist in English
they don't have it what do you they
don't have it you've still put it in
these places
oh you mean you import scripts from
other languages
Roger usually when people why I'm
kidding I'm teasing you okay put it in
okay um it's um okay great
all right I mean yeah fair enough
good okay so is there any more that we
need to review on this stuff other than
some final netting kinds of things we
are we gonna do that knitting now okay
so as always sounds good
all right okay stuff thank you thanks a
lot see you later